je suis xavier moreau bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous alors de
c'est d'abord la première question
quelles sont les preuves à que tu es
tient washington pour justifier ses
accusations envers moscou
en fait il n'y avait pas vraiment de
preuve c'est exactement ce que vous avez
dit dans votre reportage c'est à dire
c'est le même processus qu'on a eu pour
la sortie du traité sur les missiles
intermédiaire les etats unis sont en
train de déconstruire tout ce qu'ils
étaient construits non seulement pendant
la guerre froide mais dans la période
immédiate post guerre froide de tous les
traités qui ont été mis en place pour à
la fois limité de prolifération
nucléaire est également essayé de table
et on va dire de la raison dans la
relation entre la russie et l'otan
alors on à dire c'est le troisième
traité dont les états unis se retire en
très peu de temps depuis l'arrivée de
donald trump au pouvoir pourquoi cette
politique
je pense que le but principal qui est
l'île de raison de quelques égos raisons
liées et territoires intérieurs c'est à
dire que à mon avis train de signer de
nouveaux traités avec la russie et la
chine avant son élection pourrait pour
être un présidentissime respecté qui qui
prend les grandes décisions et qui aime
les gens la table des négociations
donc je ne suis pas trop inquiet non
plus sur la la prolongation de ces
traités et également le fait que
désormais donald trump inclure la chine
dans ces traités effectivement la chine
est une puissance économique
industrielle et de plus en plus
militaire et qu'effectivement avoir des
traités uniquement la russie et les
etats unis
nan dans le sens que cela avait à
l'époque de la gare tous étaient les
deux blondes qui s'affrontaient quelque
10 des moutons oui à laisser aller les
choses en fait donc voilà l'idée donald
trump c'est d'amener ces tyrans
d'inclure la machine dont s'est traité
de non-prolifération danser turgot des
territoires mais pourquoi justement
inclure la chine s pour des intérêts
stratégiques avec pékin oui
effectivement là encore aujourd'hui
l'adversaire principal de washington
surtout dans
merrick donald trump n'est pas dans le
site d'adversaires principal c'est c'est
la chine qui est paris valent désormais
très important de deux décennies et il
doit aussi que c est d'accord du survol
des territoires on donne pas forcément
les résultats que les occidentaux et
espérer qu'en 2014 lorsque les avions de
l'otan survoler le territoire russe ils
ont utilisé par préparation des bases en
ukraine ce qui était alors le le le
récit officiel des occidentaux donc ces
survols de livres d'état du riz
territoire us n'apporte pas forcément ce
que les américains voudraient dit à vis
de la russie mais je pense que le point
essentiel c'est avait amené la chine
dans tous les frais père d'un mathieu
nault pour été signé à l'époque de la
guerre froide et de 4,3 et pour donald
trump de se permettre
si le mois de novembre deux signé
plusieurs traités de colombiens sont
traités d'avoir l'air de dallara
résidents qui est capable de justement
de traiter des discussions entre les
internationaux
alors on l'a dit un l'otan va se réunir
aujourd'hui en urgence le kremlin a
dénoncé un coup porté à la sécurité
européenne
à votre avis que va décider
l'organisation et notamment la france
laquelle est moins encline que d'autres
pays européens a dénoncé la russie
écoutez jusqu'à présent la france et une
otan s'est alignée sur la position des
états unis on l'a vu sur le la sortie du
sur le traité des missiles intermédiaire
stoltenberg a dit que c'est la russie
fait qu'il voulait
effectivement notre équipe était équipé
de missiles de portée intermédiaire et
le drian le ministère des affaires
étrangères avec les a défendues françois
hollande a dit la même chose donc de
l'otan il a regardé attendre c'est une
américaine contrôlée par la scène
ricains et le mail cité du bout des
gants tout le monde suivra tout le monde
c'est essentiellement les deux goals
trois grands pays de l'otan c'est à dire
merci beaucoup
xavier moreau d'avoir répondu à nos
questions